i'm here with ross matthews who has
changed into
yes the ruby red flipper hi hi yeah i
was a tornado now i'm a ruby red slipper
but i can still twirl hi
yeah you can i can't celebrate halloween
without candy ross
and we're about to learn some tips and
tricks on how to repurpose
leftover candy if there's any left over
i was just gonna say
but if there is the luxury of leftover
candy
what do we do with it how do we be
inventive crafty and creative
i don't know well she comes up with the
most incredible ideas and creations for
parties and beyond she's author
crafter and editor and owner of darcy
miller designs
plus you work with the one and only
martha stewart for 25 years the
authority
my good friend please welcome darcy
miller yes
darcy first of all looking good just
call me dorothy
um dorothy miller exactly by the way
that kind of works for today
people call me dorothy anytime so i just
feel right at home yeah and i'm a friend
of dorothy
oh yes you are oh yeah you are an
fod for sure um and you have a little
friend with you
of course toto toto toto likes candy
yes he does and your little dog too you
look so perfect
so darcy you're gonna show us some cool
ways how to reinvent and repurpose
leftover halloween candy what is your
first tip
okay first bake with it so over here
i've got some
um cut up candy bars chocolate bar
snickers and
all different candy bars and all you do
is you bake your brownies
take them out halfway through throughout
the oven put on the candy take them back
out
put some more on put a little chocolate
ganache which is just
chocolate bars and then voila
but a few more you have the most
delicious brownies
and then you probably take them out
halfway so they still have like that
softy gooeyness where you can shave
candy so there's kind of
layers of candy within it you know of
chocolate so
you can see um you know these i would
say are a little special brownies
but it's also a fun activity and well no
no i mean i didn't mean that no
we're talking candy there's another way
to get to us
okay i'm going back to the snickers in
the freeways
they're fun brownies to make with your
kids i
love it this next trick is great for the
kids
what is it super easy take your extra
candy
and then take some healthy snacks this
is snack mix some popcorn or dried fruit
or nuts
have them pick maybe two favorite
candies and mix it with other stuff
and then you can either use it as a
snack in a bowl or little jars so that
you can use it
during the week after school if you go
for a walk this is like a festive
trail mix exactly like a halloween
trail mix and that's my jam because i
like salty stuff
i i really have to say darcy like you
just first of all
what is that because i can smell it i
know
it's so incredible like what are you
making raw so here's the deal i like
salty things right but i would also take
a bath and caramel
it's so delicious it's so good so this
is nice and warm yeah
thank you this is um it almost looks
like i'm gonna whack somebody but no
this is caramel by the way it totally
does
totally but you know those little square
caramels that you get if you put them in
a double boiler you can melt them down
this is her tip
and then take these little apples look
she got a twig from like the tree
outside and shoved it in
and then look at this you can dip it or
sort of like
just dip it on a little day and then
look oh
with all the leftovers over here oh i'm
gonna dip it in these
sprinkles
and then you just move on to the next
how fun is that i think this is also
going to
have a future career caramel bar diy man
who knew drew i quit yeah i got a new
game
i know ross i'm sitting here slack-jawed
and dumbfounded like
how do you do this and you're like all
of a sudden like whipping them up
a full-blown candy caramel apple cake
i'm bored
okay okay mr apple you can also make a
little kit
and give it as a gift after again the
packaged caramels
the chocolate so it's really reusing
that halloween candy
the way that you display your artistic
crafty
love of life is very poetic and
meaningful and thank you
so much for teaching us what we can do
with leftover candy
you